tonight's are going to meet a lawyer
named Rob Balad took on a giant
corporation whose chemicals are now in
the blood of virtually every American
it's a fight that is the subject of a
new book that he has written and is
portrayed by Hollywood in a new movie
names Mark Ruffalo and I'm honored to
play the role of Rob a lot in the
upcoming film dark waters the film is
the account of how a small-town lawyer
Rob Balad took on the huge DuPont
chemical company for the last four years
helping to expose how potentially
dangerous chemicals used to make Teflon
had made their way into the blood of
almost every American whatever's killing
those cows is in the drinking water Rob
not only discovered that these toxic
chemicals were building up in our blood
he also sounded the alarm sharing what
he found with the EPA and also Rob
secured the funding through a legal
settlement with DuPont to undertake the
biggest human health study of toxic
chemicals ever but lot's crusade against
do pond got its first national attention
in a report that Rhonda Schwartz and I
filed for the ABC news program 2020
according to the federal government some
of the highest blood levels were found
in a nationwide sample of children even
DuPont says it cannot rule out the
Teflon connected products such as its
Stainmaster carpet treatment give off
the chemical although at blood levels
DuPont says are far too small to be a
problem we are confident when we say
that the fact the scientific facts
demonstrate that the material is
perfectly safe to use
uma Chaudhary a vice president of
research is the DuPont executive chosen
to publicly defend Teflon the company's
most valuable brand name
she says Teflon is completely safe even
the key chemical is in everyone's blood
everyone has it
everyone has it's in my blood your blood
possibly we do not believe there are any
adverse health effects these are good
things to have it in your blood there
are lots of chemicals that are present
in our blood in America it falls to us
the ordinary people to prove that these
chemicals are toxic before the chemical
is regulated by our government that is
simply backwards
it's the companies that make billions of
dollars producing these companies not us
the public may only now be realizing the
scope of this problem but the companies
that manufactured these chemicals have
been aware of the risks for decades but
failed to alert the rest of us I know
because I spent the last 20 years of my
career in litigation with these
companies pulling out of their own
internal files what was already there
and was already known about the risks
cuz of eve's chemicals and we're now
joined by robbed a lot the lawyer who
Mark Lafleur calls a hero and the author
of a new book chronicling his efforts
exposure mr. Vallot thank you so much
for doing here DuPont says of the new
movie that features your efforts that
misrepresents and mischaracterizes
executives and employees and actions
associated with historic DuPont in
decades past saying it's entirely in the
realm of make-believe what do you say
well I think that's one of the main
reasons why I wanted to make sure that
this book was available to the public
and for the movie dark waters were for
people to see the the actual events here
of what really transpired that this
really happened you know this happened
in our country in the United States
during modern times during our lifetimes
where you've got contamination on a
global scale unprecedented you know
contamination of drinking water soil all
over the country all over the planet and
in all virtually every living creatures
blood humans polar bears you name it and
so I wanted to make sure all of the
history of what actually has happened
what we do
actually know what the facts actually
are are in the book in exposure
everybody can go look and see for
themselves where the truth actually lies
here and Rob were also joined tonight by
Bucky Bailey whose mother worked at that
DuPont plant in Parkersburg West
Virginia and was born with severe birth
defects Bucky was also portrayed in the
movie dark waters so Bucky thank you for
being here when we first met you for our
report on twenty twenty years ago you
were just getting married and concerned
that given the high levels of the
chemical in your blood any children you
might have had would have suffered the
same plight
so Bucky bring us up to date well it
took us several years to get to a point
where we wanted to have children just
due to the struggles that I faced in my
life
genetics told us that uh my children
would have a 50% chance of contracting
the same birth deformities so it took us
quite a few years to get to a point
where we did finally through prayer and
faith we made the choice and I now have
two beautiful children three-year-old
son and a two month old daughter and
they are the love of my life and I'm
supremely blessed that's great news a
question now from our control room and
executive producer Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda
so Rob you were able to get an
astonishing DuPont settled with you for
six hundred fifty million dollars if you
had thirty five hundred clients but what
about Bucky Bailey's Bar in there you
know unfortunately the scope of the
study that was done you know we set up
this massive human health study to try
to have independent scientists look at
all of the data including what was in
DuPont's internal files including their
own study which showed that two out of
the seven women at the DuPont plant had
children with these defects including
unfortunately Bucky as we all know and
that the panel we put together an
independent panel to look at all that
data try to do a bigger study so that
they could get enough cases and enough
instances to be able to confirm which
diseases were linked they were able to
link six different diseases including
two types of cancer but
fortunately there just weren't enough
cases with the burst effects to confirm
that link and I think we're all hoping
that with additional studies and
hopefully with even bigger studies that
possibly national studies that that will
eventually be confirmed and we'll know
one way or the other finally so Rob a
lot you're still fighting with DuPont
yes we actually still have cases that
are pending we as you heard we had a
settlement in 2017 for about 3500 people
we had one of the six diseases linked to
drinking this chemical in their water
that was the settlement for about 671
million and 20 2017 unfortunately
because of so many how many people have
been exposed we've got people who are
being diagnosed with these diseases
almost every day so additional cases
have been filed those cases are now
pending and DuPont is choosing to fight
every one of those cases in court we've
also filed a new case where we are
seeking to try to get independent
scientists to look not just at PFOA but
at this wider group of fifa's chemicals
that we now know are out there in our
water in our blood and to independently
confirm what this larger group of
chemicals will do on a national scale
that's pending right now in federal
court in Ohio and Bucky Bailey let me
ask you you're still in the fight
yourself you're eager to make sure
nobody suffers what you went through
absolutely I'm honored to play my part
in it
and staying with Robb staying with mr.
Ruffalo and others who are fighting I've
met numerous people who have been
impacted by this and still continue to
be impacted by this and I will do my
very best to shout it from the rooftops
that we cannot move forward like this we
need change and that changes what do you
think regulation we need to have this
chemical stop we need to understand
exactly the impact that it has which we
have that in our hands now and now we
are waiting for Congress we're waiting
for our government to enforce it we know
what the studies have shown we know the
whole
effects it has on us we can't continue
to go about thinking that there's no
effect and Rob bluntly asked you in
Washington you're not getting that great
of a reception are you from this current
administration well you know this has
been a process now that's been going on
for almost twenty years through multiple
administrations and you know we're
really hoping that people realize this
is not a political issue I mean it
shouldn't be a partisan issue I mean it
shouldn't be red or blue democrat or
republican we're talking about clean
water clean blood in a clean environment
something I would hope all of us support
but moving this through the regulatory
system and it's one of the things I try
to explore more detail in the book
exposure and you see that played out in
and ain't taking long the long process
in the movie dark waters as well this
takes a long time to move through this
regulatory system in the United States
and in the meantime at least we've got
states that are trying to move forward
and fill that gap and protect people in
the meantime you know I'm really hoping
that people see what but what people
like Bucky Bailey and mr. Tennant did
standing up one person you know can can
make a huge change by just standing up
and saying we're not gonna we're not
gonna put up with this and things need
to be different well you both have made
a huge change congratulations to you rob
the lot and Bucky Bailey thank you so
much for joining us tonight
and congratulations on the movie and
your new book exposure thank you very
much glad to be here